foreign
[Music]
I'm here again at the shop of Marshall
brene we just finished filming a couple
videos in which we put on some gut Frets
on a classical guitar for the first time
and you can check those videos out here
but I'm still here and we have just cut
off all the Frets and I couldn't
possibly have you know missed the
opportunity to try to play some
classical guitar on a fretless
instrument
so in this video I'm going to goof
around and see if I can play some
classical guitar pieces without frets
foreign
[Music]
sounds hilarious
partially it's because I'm really
guessing at the exact pitch but also
because you know without the frets
I think we have no sustain you know
[Music]
somehow on ooze they've managed to make
it have tons of sustain still but here
it's like everything is pits
you know
[Music]
thank you foreign
chords are like impossible
[Music]
I give up I'll try the fast variation
from the Mozart variations
[Music]
every time I have to shift it just
becomes this hilarious slide
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh my God
[Music]
that was painful I'm gonna try a little
improvisation now
[Music]
open D major chord
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so the only thing keeping me on track
here is the fact that the the slots here
have been already cut for new Frets so I
can kind of see a line here but still
like even if I try to go right on top of
the line
it's like a half a millimeter completely
changes the pitch so they can possible
to play Good Chords
today's video is brought to you by
classical guitar Pro that's my brand new
online classical guitar course which is
six hours 53 videos it's a whole
curriculum designed to teach you what
you would normally learn in the first
six months to a year of classical guitar
lessons so if you want to learn
classical guitar but are stuck
struggling reading music or struggling
to learn the techniques check out
classicalguitara dashpro.com to learn
more you know would be great is romantic
music because they really love all those
really big portamento those slides so
let's see if it works let's try some
Chopin
foreign
[Music]
yeah I think if Chopin was alive he'd
never forgive me for that one
[Music]
so my conclusion is basically everything
I play on a frontless guitar sounds
pretty stupid and it's really showing me
how much I rely on the Frets you know we
don't think about it but I think it's
like the feel of the Fret on the very
side of your finger that kind of orients
me it's not just your eyes because you
can play with your eyes closed but here
I just feel uh completely lost
foreign
[Music]
I just realized I can totally play mood
music now
[Music]
foreign
I think it's safe to say I'm going to
stick with playing threats I'm hopeless
without them so I'm gonna go back to
Marshall and have him put some metal
threats on this we're in another video
we're going to compare it to gut Frets
so again if you missed that video I'm
sure you can now check it out it should
be uh officially public at this point so
check that out thanks for watching I'll
see you guys next time
thank you
foreign
[Music]